so you've probably heard of BASE jumping
but do you really know what bass stands
for is actually an acronym which
represents the four different objects at
a base jump a good leap from
sigh with building this one's a tricky
one because it can involve legalities
there is adrenaline when you're sneaking
into a building it's something different
for base jumpers
moving on to antenna way out in the
middle of nowhere you'll see that tall
antenna a phase jumper they're probably
looking at that thing going like that's
the one to jump so span is bridges or
say hot-air balloons and this is
relatively safer jump because there's
like 360 degrees room for error if your
parachute opens incorrectly there's time
to correct it and then finally we have
earth earth basically is cliffs
it definitely tends to be the more like
eye candy to see and someone running and
jumping from a cliff edge is pretty damn
and there we have it building antenna
span F is BASE jumping
elephants are terrified because they
literally don't want to have a bee of
their trunk stinging them